how do you answer the statement there
are no shortcuts when it comes to making
or marketing great movies who said that
well you know it it's you know I'll put
it to you this way you're you you the
filmmaking the cinematography the
performance is they're all craft they're
all they're all they're all about taking
people who have done what they are doing
so many times that when you give them
something they haven't done before they
have the weight of all the things that
they have done so that they can step
into that unfamiliar territory and
suddenly find themselves at home and
take that leap of faith so you need to
make sure that you have the people who
have that basis and you need to give
them the time to make that step every
film has a different production process
but I'm a big believer in rehearsals as
a whole preparation preparation
preparation and follow through follow
through follow through and the same is
true of the cultivation of your audience
you cannot let you were talking about
the two years with paranormal activity
before they could release in theaters
two years with Napoleon down in my two
years we think if you think it's going
to take you three months you're crazy
you're not paying attention you do not
have the 20 million dollars to brand
that film and even the movies that are
spending 20 million to brand them aren't
necessarily coming off all that well
these days community technology has
caught back up you know what I mean to
where it was when Shakespeare was
telling plays now its global now your
community is everywhere and it turns out
it's stronger it works better than
branding it just takes a long time to
build start right now because and do not
relent do not ever relent and approach
your film with the same work ethic and
the same demand for professionalism and
excellence every single day from every
single person never bring anybody in
who's going to create risk always bring
people in who challenge your film to
become better
you